what is going on everybody welcome to
part 7 of our Python with PI QT tutorial
video series in this video what we're
going to be talking about is a pop-up
message so sometimes you want to have
like a final alert to the user before
something happens and we're going to use
it on our quitting method so like I
promise we're going to make our quitting
method a little more complex than it was
up to this point and so anytime you have
like maybe a quit the application any
sort of deleting save overwriting you
know that kind of stuff
generally you're going to want to have
like a are you sure you want to do this
because people are going to miss click
they're going to make mistakes and so on
so let's go ahead and talk about how
we're going to do that so all of our new
code is actually going to be contained
within our closed application method
first of all we don't need this whoa so
custom any more and it's just out exit
we're just going to remove for now we're
going to put it back but it's just going
to get in the way so first of all when
this method runs it means someone has
clicked something that means to exit the
application so what we want to do is
first we're going to say choice because
we're going to pop up a little window
that says like are you sure and it's
going to be a binary yes or no so choice
is going to equal Qt GUI queue message
box dot question and just keep in mind
there are message boxes and there's also
multiple forms of message boxes so this
one's just the question so it comes up
and it'll have this nice little question
mark and it'll be clear it's a question
box so that question self and we'll just
make the title this is the title of the
window and we'll just make it extract
and then comma we'll hit enter just to
make some space and then we'll have it
ask the question and the question for
this one will be get into the chopper
and then now you have your choices and
your choices are going to be a binary
set of choices and you basically have QT
GUI cue message box dot yes and then you
have a little bar that denotes either-or
and then you have the same thing
only it's gonna be no so let's just take
this copy-paste no although it would be
pretty funny to replace no make both of
these no that would be pretty fun just
like our little s up here anyway this is
why I don't have any applications you
know a Q message box yes/no so you have
the choices and then once they choose
choice will either be QT message box yes
object or it'll be a dot no so then what
we're going to do is we're going to say
if the choice is equal to a QT GUI Q
message box dot yes what we want to do
is we're going to be we're let's just
say print extracting now or we're at
well actually we need to go ahead and
extract so cysts out exit and then else
if they didn't you know if they say like
no well all we need to do is like just
pass okay that's it so that's that
that's pretty much all we should have to
do so let's go ahead and save and run
that and see how that works
hood okay here's our application so we
should in theory get that no matter if
we exit hit quit or hit this little
baby's face so let's hit the baby in the
face and we see okay we've got this
little this new window and the quits
nice question mark it's got our logo
still pretty cool extract and the
question is get into the choppa and we
could say no nothing happens but if we
click it and say yes it extracts us from
the application pretty cool so another
thing to note is if you'll see we have
this little logo here and we hit quit
that logo is still on our window so
tkinter why don't you you know take
notes anyway so that's that that's how
we can kind of add this not only a popup
message but also make our close
application make a little more sense
because people are going to make
mistakes they're going to mean to
maximize maybe and they just barely miss
click oh that one actually closed my
goodness I guess that one's probably
that's a shame
that's probably because the this frame
is defined
see so far what we've
find up to this point is we've got this
in it but this is our window right
don't forget our entire application
don't forget like me our entire
applications defined here so you'd have
to change that before you know that how
that's handled but otherwise or other
handling under control q better yeah our
control Q does it so everything except
for the frame basically I wonder how you
would modify that there's a homework for
you guys if anybody knows how you would
edit that I'll have to look into it
because that's a obviously something I
think you should change I'm sure there's
a way especially with QT but anyway
that's at for now if you guys have any
questions comments up to this point
besides hey you're stupid that X didn't
work keep that to yourself
questions or nice comments please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all this for the subscriptions until
next time